ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt und meine lieben freunde hier seht
schon die brücke die wir hier in der
letzten episode gebaut haben sie steht
auf jeden fall noch das freut mich
extrem und was mich auch extrem freut
ist dass das gras sie vorüber gewachsen
ist da wo wir zwei und in die kommentare
geschrieben luca menschen kannst nicht
nur gras zu einem trampelpfad machen
sondern auch ganz normale erde
das funktioniert leider nicht denn ich
spiele nicht die beta version sondern
die java version und da geht das nur mit
gras und was mir auch geschrieben wurde
bei luca du musst das nicht immer so
verbinden
graz wird auch ganz normal auf erde
wachsen ohne dass es mit anderen grad
verbunden ist und da bin ich mir nicht
ganz sicher
ich baue das hier einfach mal so auf als
kleinen test und dann schauen wir am
ende der folge p gras darüber gewachsen
ist allerdings wird mir auch in die
kommentare geschrieben luca du hast hier
noch eine schatzkarte und hier vorne
auch die hattest du in der letzten folge
noch nicht gesucht die schätze von daher
würde ich erst euch erstmal jetzt hier
ganz kurz eine time labs einblenden wie
wir wieder dort hinten hinfahren wo ich
die schätze gefunden habe wie die
schatzkarten gefunden habe und wir
suchen dort jetzt mal den schatten
oh mein gott nach 70 jahren endlich
gefunden
dazu glücks in der diamanten drin ich
wäre das ding jetzt auch markt endlich
komplett abbauen so dass wir hier nicht
die ganzen sachen raus nehmen müssen das
hat jetzt aber auch lange genug gedauert
guckt euch das mal hier an jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon in der time nichts
gesehen
ich habe hier alles umgebaut einfach die
sonne geht da hinten schon wieder unter
also mal ganz schnell hier ein brötchen
reinen snacken schatzkarte schmeiß dich
weg die brauchen wir nicht mehr da wurde
mir auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben luca mit einer schatzkarte
pass auf wenn die andere schatzkarte
öffnet das du die andere schon
weggeschmissen hast denn sonst zeigt sie
den gleichen schatz an und so weiter und
so fort die sache allerdings ich habe
das alles in einer test welt getestet
mit den verschiedenen tipps und tricks
auch mit 100 blöcke irgendwie was
brauchen die kommentare geschrieben das
hat alles nichts gebracht als die
schatzkarten die ich immer irgendwo
gefunden habe meiner test welt haben
immer den gleichen schatz angezeigt also
wenn einer von euch da eventuell
unfassbare baba ahnung von hat charme
und in die kommentare ich würde euch
allerdings ganz kurz noch mal eben eine
timeline blenden bis wir an unserem haus
angekommen sind
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder in
unserer kleinen insel hier angekommen
meine lieben freunde ihr merkt schon es
ist nacht mittlerweile geworden und ich
hoffe dass wir jetzt eventuell mal einen
zombie sehen werden denn dann seht ihr
da vorne kommt erstmal ein skelett mit
dem verzauberten bogen sogar dann hörte
ich zum ersten mal was moment ist ja
richtig stark mit dem bogen
dann hörte ich nämlich auf jeden fall
zum aller ersten mal was der neue zombie
sound ist ich habe mir gedacht dass ich
nicht nur für krieg jetzt einen sound
einblenden möchte sondern auch für
zombies erst mal ganz kurz gucken den
bogen das skelett leider nicht fallen
lassen wir sehen allerdings bisher auch
noch keinen zombie wurde die kommentare
geschrieben ich finde es passt einfach
perfekt weil damals aber treu mix hier
drin wenn greta kommt und der raum zum
bis dahin hund ein kompletter gold
prüfen
also so viele babys wollte ich jetzt
doch nicht so richtig haben in meiner
welt ich würde allerdings sagen dass ich
mich mal ganz kurz eben schnell schlafen
lege und mich dann davon habe ich
während skelett schon ein
ich werde ganz viel hätte nicht auch
noch einen sound einfügen denn dann
haben wir irgendwann nur noch sounds
also ich werde mal ganz kurz schlafen
legen und mich vorbereiten auf unsere
erkundungstour
[Musik]
so ich bin mehr oder weniger fertig
ausgerüstet meine lieben freunde bevor
wir allerdings losfahren noch ganz kurz
eine schweigeminute für die verstorbenen
mitglieder unserer insel das sollten wir
generell viel häufiger machen denn die
haben so viel geschichte einfach und das
tun wir einfach leid dass ich damals
außer seine kuh getötet habe und auch
das mit dem pilz kühner wer braucht man
halt einfach die bücher und ihr seht
doch schon ich befinde mich gerade
wieder drin denn ich möchte die wieder
so ein bisschen vermehren
ganz einfach aus dem grund weil ich
jetzt meine schere nehmen und eine von
denen zu einer normalen hatte von denen
ich mir dann einen milch einmal
mitnehmen kann das wird nämlich auch und
in die kommentare geschrieben luca wenn
du irgendwo unterwegs sein sollte es
macht ihr auf jeden fall milch einmal
damit kannst du effekte auf jeden fall
weg machen die plötzlich kommen und dass
sie hier auch schon sehe dass ich
irgendwie ein bisschen nämlich vergessen
ich habe den baum wir auch mal ein
bisschen schöner gemacht habt ihr mal
ein bisschen abgetrennt damit sie alles
ein bisschen luftiger ist und auch hier
vorne was mir auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde merkt schon wieder ich
war eine menge unterwegs das grab hier
vorne
möchte ein user beziehungsweise wurde
sich gewünscht ob ich mir nicht eine
grab insel machen kann also eine rad
friedhof beispielsweise hier vorne dann
dass wir einfach einen friedhof haben wo
wir dann für jede verstorbene person
beziehungsweise jedes verstorbene tiere
ein
ich hasse diese schildkröten meine
lieben freunde ich habe mich aufgerüstet
und ihr seht schon ich habe mir alle
sachen hier doppelt gemacht ich habe mir
ein bisschen fleisch mitgenommen für
balu der kommt nämlich auch mit
ich habe mir ein reisebett mitgenommen
und mir die kommentare geschrieben luca
gleiche reise wird gar nicht mal so eine
gute idee denn wenn ich sterben sollte
um dann das reisen bei denen wo dahin
aufgestellt habe dann sportlich dort
wieder und nicht hier auf meiner meiner
insel also es kann sein dass ich mich
verlaufen werde ich wäre allerdings
nicht sterben
bei wenig eine reise wert habe kann ich
ja logischerweise übernachten wenn es
dunkel ist dementsprechend auch keine
monster was ich auch mit dabei habe es
eine schere falls wir schafe finden
sollten ich habe eine andere mitgenommen
der mir wurde auch unten in die
kommentare geschrieben mensch luca du
kannst eventuell einfach mit einer angel
die ich behandele ich stehe schon wieder
vor neben der spur weil du sitzt schon
im boot drin perfekt das heißt sie
können direkt los wir können heute nicht
los hab mich hier nämlich ausgerüstet
ein fischer hut und einem jutebeutel
weil ich habe jeder wenn wir auf reisen
gehen mensch wir nehmen so viel mit und
wir müssen ja auch selbst regeln muss
man ja gewappnet sein
da habe ich mich gedacht hab ich mir
gedacht tatsächlich auch vom outfit so
ein bisschen an also mal ganz kurz die
themen von von beginn von gerade zu ende
zu bringen ich hab schnell vergessen was
ich gesagt habe ich eine angel mit damit
können wir uns vielleicht irgendwie
verzauberte bücher angeht ich hab ein
bogen dabei etwas zu essen eine leine
falls für tiere finden eine schatzkarte
kartoffeln wenn sie etwas zu essen und
wir verhandeln wir noch mal hier
übernachten bevor du ja kommen wir
machen abenteuer insel hier kommen los
geht s endlich abenteuer insel machen
abenteuer mensch das fühlt sich an wie
wenn man den hamburg in seinem riesigen
dampfer sitzt und dann oder von aida
kreuzfahrtschiffen und hermann etwas los
und die ganze stadt wieder einen zusatz
zu viel spaß da in norwegen oder
dänemark oder keine ahnung wo die
schiffe da hinfahren können von hamburg
das ist ich gar keinen sinn die schiffe
können von hamburg eigentlich überall
hinfahren
weil wenn wir auch noch da ist ja auch
kein da kommst du auch nutzen
das gibt es nicht
ich bereue es jetzt schon ehrlich gesagt
dass ich dich mitgenommen habe
allerdings habe ich letztes im hamburger
hafen einfach so wir wahrscheinlich
schon in meiner instagram story gesehen
falls es mir dort nicht folglich als
laserdrucker allerdings seht ihr schon
dass wir vorne wir sind schon angekommen
also das display ist ja tatsächlich auch
gar nicht so weit weg wir waren sind
allerdings noch nie weiter als das pils
bio deswegen habe ich mir gedacht waren
wir heute mal die richtung wir sehen da
hinten noch immer die kugel hinten in
dem boot drin sitzt und wartet also wir
allerdings erst mal ein bisschen drum
rum weil ich meine dies als bio davon
habe ich sogar noch mehr kühe
ich meine das war relativ klein also ein
bisschen rum gelaufen sind wir ja schon
deswegen macht wirklich keinen sinn wenn
ich da jetzt kurz anhalten und dann wir
schauen uns das ganze mal von außen an
und es ist ja auch der kleine boots
folge gibt es ja schon auf den tempel
gesehen da sitzt der luca kleinen drin
auf dem brötchen und fährt ihr rum und
wir entdecken dass alles so ein bisschen
um brot isst man darauf deutlich
schneller als auf dem land plus wir
verbrauchen keinen hunger keulen also
müssen nicht so viel essen denn wir
haben auch gar nicht mehr so viel
kartoffeln
jetzt geht die sonne allerdings ist
schon ziemlich krass und also ich würde
sagen wir machen hier nur ganz kurze
rast und ich werde jetzt mal mit
reisebett nehmen dass hier hinsetzen und
eine runde schlafen
[Musik]
nein bisher fest
so gibt
[Musik]
so wir gehen schlafen meine lieben
freunde das ist glaube ich doch ein
bisschen entspannter wenn wir bei tag
rumfahren klar bei nacht ist auch cool
aber dann können wir auf jeden fall uns
noch ein bisschen umgucken und können
auch alles sehen also bei luca mit hier
vorne in das brötchen reingelaufen
perfekt der ist drin die sonne geht da
hinten auf wir haben unsere welt ja dort
hinten und würde sagen dass wir jetzt am
pilz mir vorbei sind von anfang an die
richtung weiter
quermann ozean obwohl wir können auch
mal ganz kurz hier an so einem frühen
morgendlichen tag können wir ganz kurz
unsere anderen auspacken und vielleicht
fallen bei uns der direkten schönes
brötchen oder irgendwie buch büchlein
oder irgendwie sowas also abwarten meine
lieben freunde vielleicht kommt jetzt
das große glück wir brauchen wir immer
noch ein treuebruch wir brauchen und
endlichkeit unseren bogen und sowas kann
man halt einfach am besten bekommen wenn
man angelt ich habe zwar kein glück auf
meiner allerdings haben wir unsere
minecraft welt kenner der eine menge
glück von daher meine lieben freunde was
wir alle werden ist das was ich jetzt
gleich aus dem wasser ziehen werde
denn wir alle in uns zusammen denn heute
wir scheißen aufsammeln meine lieben
freunde ich glaube ich muss mir das
wirklich so eine glücks angel mal machen
oder so wenn ihr tipps gerne in die
kommentare mir wird auch geschrieben
lukat macht doch mal so lange live
stream oder hätten schon wieder unter
wasser das er ist schon wieder sagt doch
schon wieder unter wasser denn jede
menge seetang rum
[Musik]
ich will eigentlich nicht mehr
eigentlich möchte ich das nicht kommt
ich nehme hier die packende linke hand
dann seht ihr ein bisschen was wir
schauen uns das mal ganz kurz an
ich habe eigentlich immer ein bisschen
schiss dass da jetzt irgendwie wieder so
ein typ mit sommern sondern mistgabel
ankommt da lob ich mir extra ein
bisschen weiter hinten wir schauen uns
das aber wirklich nur ganz kurz an der
front kommt schon wieder jemand der hat
nichts in der hand den normalen
unterwasser zombies sind auch überhaupt
nicht schwer zu besiegen das stück so
wirklich nur zweimal gegen bzw
einmal und dann hast du die halt
er kam aber auch immer mehr
ich würde gern einmal um ein
[Musik]
ist er denn
mehr
da hinten ist der ort mit seinen
mistgabel
da bin ich bei meinen weg weiter
zweieinhalb herzen weil er nicht einmal
getroffen
wir haben hier keine action heute freuen
ich möchte einfach nur ein bisschen
entdecken ich möchte eine boots folge
machen ich möchte auch nicht sterben wir
haben 22 leben ich habe extra das
reisebett mitgenommen wo kritik geübt
wurde
aber ich werde nicht sterben ich werde
heute nicht sterben sie entdecken heute
einfach ein bisschen schön ich werde
nicht sterben weil du dankeschön das ist
ja auch mega vertrauen in mich hast ich
möchte einfach nur eine erkundungs folge
heute machen und da freue ich mich drauf
für mich und diese erkundungs folge mit
die coolsten folgenden projekt ich finde
wir die folgen wenn ich mal ein bisschen
langweilig sie sind aber glaube ich
tatsächlich nur für mich langweilig weil
ich das ja immer schon meine tests welt
[Musik]
das sah mir gerade nicht nach einem
normalen baum aus ich weiß nicht ob ich
da wieder meine brille aufsetzen sollte
mal schauen wir mal ganz kurz an
aluh ich nehme ich jetzt mal nicht an
die leine du kannst auch ganz normalen
hier rumlaufen
aber das sei gerade schon das sah mir
ein bisschen suspekt aus ja meine lieben
freunde wir befinden uns auf dem
festland ich habe mein brötchen dabei
ich habe meinem bett dabei und ich haben
einen dabei also egal was uns erwarten
sollte wir sind auf jeden fall gut
ausgestattet und werden jetzt einmal so
ein bisschen rum entdeckt dahin ist ein
lama sie okay hier ist wir haben der das
kannst du doch wirklich nicht ausdenken
was bei unserer web abgeht
ich gehe ganz kurz aufs festland und wir
finden instant ein dorf guck mal hier
das verrottete fleisch kann ich mal ganz
kurz nehmen und balu geben
erfreut er sich rw finthen einfach
direkten dorf wie kann das denn sein
[Musik]
aber mir schon das ist doch haben wir
schon mal entdeckt die langen verfolger
des projektes wissen auf jeden fall
bescheid da hatten wir sogar überfall am
start ich glaube das war sogar der erste
überfall mit dem wir jemals zu tun
hatten
wir werden heute auf jeden fall kein
überfall am start haben denn wir werden
entdecken meine lieben freunde darauf
freue ich mich extrem wird auch und in
die kommentare geschrieben das habt ihr
da hinten glaube ich schon eingeblendet
sehe nirgendwo dass dieses bikes
billionen was wir dort hinten hat mit
diesem komischen jetzt sieht man es
nicht mehr mit diesen riesigen türmen
und so dass das wohl eines der
seltensten biome ist und ich freue mich
wohl immer darüber dass ich irgendwie
diamanten finden und so aber ich finde
wohl auch im die spikes bio mit die man
wohl gar nicht irgendwie so richtig
findet und ich werde mich jetzt auch
nicht so richtig auf die kohle
konzentrieren ich weiß ich will immer
alles mitnehmen
ich finde alle super in minecraft und
ich freue mich immer wenn man neue
sachen entdeckt allerdings muss ich mich
erstmal wirklich aufs entdeckten
konzentrieren und das ist ja auch der
sinn des heutigen videos von daher hier
vorne sondern schön durchgang eine menge
kühle ja wir haben eine menge gehör am
start wie könnte theoretisch auch mal
wir haben schon geführt
wir müssen jetzt nicht unbedingt kleiner
der für seine crew hier verschwinden der
mercure auf unserer welt ich springe von
thema zu thema es tut mir unfassbar leid
ich
[Musik]
ich hasse das was nicht spieltag das
leben ist viel zu schön als dass sie
jetzt da es ist gut
schweine braucht man auch deswegen
spring nicht um ganz normal runter und
wir reden darüber nicht ganz normal
unterwegs und jetzt hab ich ja gar nicht
mehr sprinten schnelle kurven hat man
jetzt haben wir hier schon selbstmord
schwein am start hier vorne yu na jetzt
muss ich ja wir haben eine mission jetzt
komm ich wieder nicht lang steht das
schwein da oben doch wir können sich mal
mehr sehen
oh gott jetzt ich will einfach nur ganz
normal entdecken und jetzt haben wir
hier solche probleme die ganze zeit
schnell hin springen zum schwein
vielleicht kann man sich davon
überzeugen dass es sich nicht um bringt
meine lieben freunde wir haben druck wir
haben wirklich zeitpunkt sagt sagt sag
ich bin so ein idiot alois schon oben
schnell wir müssen diesmal in form
ertrinken retten bzw form springen ein
kompaktes ist weg weißt du was
dann springt anspringen hier kommen
nimmt das weizen
an der wak rocknummer haben hier guck
auf die karotte cook hier
diese worte spricht idiot
ich werde mir auf jeden fall mal die
ganze wolle hier noch mal eben mit
nehmen die benötigen wir ja für unseren
leuchtturm den ich demnächst endlich mal
machen möchte da wird er auch wieder die
kommentare geschrieben luca machten
wurde leuchtturm nicht mit wolle wenn
dann blitz einschlägt dann brennt das
ding ab warum sollte dann blitz
einschlagen oder ist eine sonnenblume
auch mal mitnehmen und es ist so schön
ich finde es total will und irgendwie
neue sachen entdeckt wenn man sich
irgendwie jetzt nicht irgendwie runter
baut und sich dann denkbar da können wir
die prozentual statistisch gesehen
schneller diamanten finden und besser
die und die sachen mitnehmen und so
weiter und so fort ich finde immer
schöner wenn man sich sachen wirklich so
zurecht legt wenn man sich denkt soja
kommen wir machen jetzt mal hinten
bootstouren und entdecken wir jemals ein
paar sachen und ich weiß wolle kann ich
mir auch kräften in dem ich irgendwie
spinnen töten und an die seide zusammen
kraft und zweiter und sofort ich find's
cool einfach schafe zu suchen und die
dann zu scheren man hier vorne haben wir
auch noch ein paar da laufen als auch
mal ganz kurz in das ist auf jeden fall
interessant ist die sonnenblume in
minecraft auch tatsächlich nur bis zur
sonne hin wachsen die ja von der vorne
auf geht also faktisch noch mal ganz
kurz mit niemand die jetzt können uns
auch ganz kurz unser reisebett nehmen
dass man hier hinstellen und einfach so
in der natur schlafen ich fünf
wundervoll ich bin es wirklich geil ich
liebe dieses spiel bei alles ich glaube
das merkt man auch wenn ich wie ich hier
die ganze zeit darüber sprechen wir
haben hier freunde noch schafe das ist
doch wahnsinn ich liebe diese entdeckung
folgen ich sehe so oft in den
kommentaren dass leute auch die bau
folgen 60 finden für mich sind die halt
wirklich eher langweilig weil ich die
ganzen sachen immer schon in der test
welt vorbereitet und dann theoretisch
eigentlich nur noch nach baue in meiner
richtigen welt die vorne guckt euch mal
an wie schön das aussieht die sind ja
auch schon wieder in schwarz eichenbaum
so ein bisschen näher mit den ganzen
pilzen und so laufen über stock und
stein also ich bin auf jeden fall
gespannt was wir hier heute noch alles
entdecken werden sie in harrow aufnahme
schon dass wir bei über eineinhalb
stunden sind also die folge wird auch
schon wieder über länger habe
eigentlich wollten die folgen hier alle
so auf 15 minuten packen so dass das so
dieser standard länge ist allerdings
finde ich es sollte dann auch immer so
ein bisschen
[Musik]
sind im kampf wir sind mal wieder im
kampf meine lieben freunde
wir haben hier wieder eine festung
beziehungsweise sondern villiger alten
posten
keine ahnung wie die teile genau heißen
allerdings werden wir schon wieder von
allen seiten attackiert bei lewis mit am
start
ich möchte hier gar keinen großen stress
ich weiß dass die nicht so krass stark
sind allerdings möchte ich mich nur
darauf konzentrieren was wir dort oben
drin haben wir hatten bisher nie glück
als die sonne komische festung gefunden
haben wir hatten immer nur komische
schmutz items oben drin wie kohle oder
weizen oder irgendwas allerdings haben
wir hier ist
haltbarkeit 3 ist in schwarz eichen
kartoffeln erfahrungs fläschchen kann
ich auf den boden schmeißen
[Musik]
wir haben auf jeden fall hier vorne eine
menge schweine wir haben hier vorne auch
noch eine menge schafe er gehe ich auch
mal direkt hin und homogener man die
volle so ein bisschen zack zack und hier
vorne und bei dir hier vorne auch noch
zack und hier vorne haben wir sogar auch
noch ein paar mehr schafe das ist halt
echt der vorteil den sonne prärie
landschaft beziehen wir eine ganz
normale minecraft welt meiner welt
gegenüber bietet denn auf einem ozean
ja da denke ich jetzt nicht so viele
schafe mensch da will ich leben
natürlich auch verständlich deswegen
freue ich mich auf jeden fall irgendwann
vielleicht auch staffel 2 dieses
projektes hier abfolge 100 oder so ich
weiß noch nicht muss ich mir noch mal
gedanken darüber machen dass wir dann
vielleicht andere mit der map am start
wir haben hundertprozentige anderem vom
staat aber vielleicht ja hier so eine
map in der wir dann auf dem land
unterwegs und das kann ich auch mal ganz
cool haben auch ganz ganz andere
möglichkeiten was das angeht hier vorne
sind auf jeden fall in dem village am
start ich weiß gar nicht was das hier
vorne für blöcke sind ich dass sie mal
was ist das hier das ist weiß er gesagt
palucca und dadurch direkt rein was ist
das hier das nachbildung aus glaube ich
das ist tonklumpen orgel ok den sich der
mann direkt da wieder hin und klumpen
brauche ich nicht ich brauche auch nicht
die keramik hier von denen das ist weiße
keramik pink oder so
das ist doch nicht weiß und pink das
aussieht damit damit den leuchtturm
bauen sollen alter da will ich aber ein
weiteres material haben auf jeden fall
das soll so richtig catchy sein weiß rot
wir haben hier vorne auf jeden fall auch
noch ein häuschen hier ist nur ein bett
drin zwei betten sogar haben wir
infokästen hier ist eine kiste da haben
wir bücher brote und äpfel die betten
lasse ich hier mal stehen vielleicht
sollten wir auf unserer insel auch man
zwei etagen hohes haus bauen hier vorne
haben wir leder drin und auch noch eine
rote leder kann ich nicht mitnehmen dass
man die pilze hier
hier haben wir nichts mehr am start wir
haben hier vorne noch häuschen wir haben
da oben noch was wir haben hier noch
häuschen wir haben da hinten gibt es
auch noch weiter wir haben auch und
generell wie viele wieder sinken
schiebe ich nicht so rum balu es muss ja
okay das ist auf jeden fall ein riesiges
häuschen ich würde
deswegen sagen meine lieben freunde wir
haben hier vorne auch noch eine schlucht
was gibt denn hier jetzt plötzlich ab
sogar der weg weiter vielleicht finden
wir ja dort einige diamanten allerdings
in der nächsten folge meine lieben
freunde denn an der stelle will ich die
heutige episode minecraft mit lukas auch
beenden meine lieben freunde ich bin
schon wieder seit sehr langer zeit im
aufnehmen ich hoffe allerdings es hat
euch gefallen diese entdeckung folge
heute wenn ihr tipps hat für dieses dorf
ihr wenn ihr tipps für die schlucht da
unten oder wenn ihr generell vorschläge
habt was ich in der nächsten folge alles
machen soll
dann schreiben wir uns in die kommentare
das einen daumen hoch oder ein video da
wenn es euch gefallen hat und abonniert
main kanal falls doch keiner der lose
seiten plus klickt auf die glocke und
dann bekommt er eine benachrichtigung
sobald ein neues video von der online
geht
in letzter zeit hat youtube auf probleme
stellt meine videos nicht richtig online
pünktlich um 20 uhr dann kommt eine
halbe stunde später wegen abonnieren
glocke klicken und bei instagram folgen
da wagen
[Musik]